[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
welcome to the bonus show just a
reminder i'm going to do this many times
this week we will be off next week for
our end of the year vacation the show
will not have ended and everything will
be fine but we will be not producing new
shows
and we will not be posting old shows to
the website
member portal there will just be nothing
there for the
for next week okay tons of news over the
weekend
about the new strain of covid19 that has
been identified
in england some accurate things are
being said about it
and then other things are being said for
which we don't yet have evidence i want
to be careful how i say that pat there
are things being said which could be
true but for we
which we don't yet have evidence so
let's go through it
the top medical officer in england said
saturday
that there is a new variant of
coronavirus that can spread more quickly
than prior strains
now very important to know spreading
more quickly
does not necessarily mean um more deadly
and so far there is no evidence
that this new strain is more deadly now
it does stand to reason
that if it spreads more easily if every
person
gives it to more people and the
mortality remains the same
it can still lead pat to more people
dying right now the question is whether
by spreading more quickly it's less it's
less deadly and this sometimes happens
with viruses where
the really deadly ones spread very
slowly because they kill you so quickly
you don't get a chance to give it to
anybody else
sometimes the ones that spread really
easily like for example
the h1n1 situation years ago
it's less deadly it spreads really
easily but it has
lower mortality right now all we can say
pat is
this um spreads more quickly no evidence
that causes more severe disease
no evidence it has higher mortality
that's really what we can say right now
and it may take weeks or months before
we know if it has higher mortality but
as you point out even if it's the exact
same mortality rate
then we still have to be concerned
because if more people are getting it
then statistically more people are going
to die from it
and we're seeing uh countries in europe
and around the world start to place
travel restrictions on the uk because
we don't exactly know what's going on
yet with this new strain
and certainly we don't want it to spread
to other places in the world
the us was actually supposed to have its
ban on uk travel lifted
this week it doesn't seem like that's
going to happen anymore but still
u.s citizens can come into the country
some are returning for christmas
and that's going to be a problem if you
have a u.s citizen who is in the uk
right now
gets this new strain brings it over here
to the u.s then we all of a sudden have
another problem here in this country
and it seems like maybe we're not
learning from the mistakes that we made
early on with the virus we're going
going to continue to make mistakes when
it comes to travel restrictions and all
this stuff
the other piece we didn't talk about but
is important is
does the vaccine work do the vaccines
work against this strain
again as of right now we are told there
is no evidence that the vaccinations
the vaccines that are approved and in
development will not work
but that is something that is being as
the word they use was
urgently tested in the uk that's what
they said but again
we don't have reason right now pat to
believe that the vaccines will not work
against this variant
yeah so that's also very very good news
it would be a disaster scenario if it
was more deadly and the best can you
imagine if we had to go back to
square one with vaccines yeah and uh i
mean it's already not good because
london is locking down
pretty hardcore at this point they were
hoping to be open for
christmas and that no longer can happen
but it's good at least
that they're adjusting with what the
science tells them you know if the
strain comes here to the us
i would imagine that we wouldn't have
any major changes in how we do things
here
maybe like city and local governments
would change their policy more be more
strict with the lockdowns and stuff but
i think nationwide we would continue to
have the same approach it seems pretty
clear that that's uh
that that's what it's going to be um
okay so we'll follow that
and and that uh seems to be uh the
what is becoming the predominant strain
in the uk and potentially soon elsewhere
as well oh by this reminds me i mean
this is maybe for offline but do we do i
know we were trying to line a few
different vaccine related people
up pat which people might find
interesting did we are we go looking
good with any of them
we have one scheduled now for the new
year okay um that is dr
eric topol oh yeah yeah working on
vaccine distribution
he'll be on january 5th beautiful so
that'll be uh that'll be in the new year
and by then we'll have a little more
data also
by then you might have will we have
anybody people it will be right around
when some people will start getting the
second dose
close not quite but it'll be close so
that's upcoming in uh in january
new york governor andrew cuomo signed a
bill into law
banning the sale or display of
confederate flags
on state property as well as other
symbols of hate
including swastikas and insignias
historically associated with racism and
violent acts
targeting religious or ethnic groups
these displays
of symbols will only be allowed if
proper educational or historical
purposes can be provided
and the law will go into effect
immediately so
to me pat this seems more about
is this more about schools and what's
allowed in schools because when you're
talking about
state grounds uh you know a private shop
that wants to sell
confederate flags will still be allowed
to
is it about at protests on state grounds
people won't be able to bring
confederate flags
i think state fairs is the big one but
you're right it's very limited because
how often are confederate flags being
sold on state grounds anyway especially
in new york which i don't know if you
know this it's a northern state
i don't know if there's like that many
confederate flags yeah but as
you know upstate new york is the further
north in new york you go
the further south it gets but does that
mean they like the confederacy and the
confederate flag i mean
that just hasn't been my experience the
eggman says that where he is
it's a lot of confederate flags yeah oh
my all right well i have a lot to learn
i guess
you know i thought this would be a very
limited thing because i was thinking who
wants to buy a confederate flag in new
york and who's doing it on state grounds
like
it seems as though andrew cuomo is
trying to send a message here against
hate speech and these hate symbols but
there's not really a lot behind
a move like this because it wouldn't
even affect all that much and you're
raising this
interesting constitutional issue but for
what purpose because
who's really going to be buying
confederate flags in new york but maybe
it is more of an issue than i once
thought
yeah i mean at the same time it may not
be that big of an issue in terms of the
number of flags that are being sold but
it is more about sending a signal as
you're pointing out by andrew cuomo i
don't know i mean
i'm not against this but at the same
time i
questioned the impact of it i guess is
where i am
yeah like if the government told private
institutions you can't sell
confederate symbols anymore i would be
against that i think that would be too
harsh of a restriction
and i think that would be
unconstitutional saying that you can't
do it on state grounds i think is more
wishy-washy right because
i mean i would imagine there are
certainly some things that the
government can
ban people from selling on state grounds
but maybe the confederate flag is
protected by the first amendment so
there's a constitutional
issue there cuomo has mentioned too that
he may have to adjust
the language in the bill uh to fit the
constitution so i think he's open to
this being shot down if that happens i'm
finding myself
a tiny bit confused by the entire thing
like if i'm completely honest
uh but let's see where it goes and see
if it's challenged in chord and and
we'll follow up
on on it if if the time comes now let me
ask you this pat
do you think in high school you would
have been allowed to wear
a confederate flag shirt for example in
school because i know that this has
become an issue in some southern schools
about schools having policies saying
it's a symbol that's not allowed
in the school i went to in northampton
massachusetts
i don't think it would ever have
occurred to anybody to bring a
confederate flag and wear one
but my instinct is that it simply would
not have been allowed even absent
a formal policy on it my thoughts
exactly i don't think
anyone would come into school with a
confederate flag shirt on but if they
did
i think a teacher would probably raise
an objection to it and they would have
to
go to the administration and change
their shirt but
i'm not sure entirely i would have to
look into the school policy on something
like that
and that's even in worcester yeah
worcester
which i mean for people who are not from
massachusetts it's a it's a less
blue part of massachusetts i think is
fair to say
yeah it's not the bluest but it's still
a city it's still somewhat urban
and you know it's it's we're not
confederates out there at least we can
say that much
have you been out recently enough to
like what's the situation with
with restaurants and like what's going
on there i haven't been out there
i just stick to boston uh these days i
don't visit family as much so i've just
been
staying around here but my friends in
worcester tell me that uh there isn't
as much mask wearing as you might expect
certainly uh boston is a lot better with
that stuff so
um you know that that's true for a lot
of places around the country that is
that is true for uh many many places
that's for sure
hey this is a kind of interesting um
series of events that's lining up on
january 6. as many of you know january
6th is the day
that the electoral votes that were cast
on december 14th within state
legislatures
will be formally counted in front of a
joint session of the house and senate
in washington dc and then that is a day
on which joe biden will again
win the presidency the win the election
i think at this point he's won like six
or seven times and that'll be
the eighth on january 6. the vice
president presides over that process
meaning mike pence is going to preside
over the counting
of the ballots which will defeat him and
remove him from office this is similar
although not exactly the same as to when
um uh al gore
wait no it is the same in a i guess it's
slightly different but
it's it's similar right because al gore
wouldn't was
you know going to become president if he
had won that election yeah as mike pence
would remain
vice president it's marginally different
al gore did it in the year 2000
but it appears as though immediately
after that hours after that event takes
place on january 6 mike spence is
leaving the country
and um it sounds sort of awkward but he
has a trip planned to the middle east
and europe and there are people
who are um coming up with all sorts of
hypotheses about the timing and and
almost getting kind of conspiratorial
i don't really think there's much to
this it seems pat as though this has
been planned for some time
and to me it doesn't seem as though it's
mike pence
fleeing or anything like that it just
seems sort of like
he's gonna try to keep being vice
president for those last
couple of weeks uh do you make more of
it than that i think he's trying to get
out of dodge because if you remember a
lot of these republicans who went
against trump
on the voter fraud narrative yeah people
like georgia governor brian kemp
they've been facing death threats when
they decided not to be completely in
line with trump
and so if mike pence has to count the
votes and certify biden's win
there are going to be trump supporters
who are upset with him maybe they'll
make attacks against him or his family
but he has secret service protection i
don't like is he really going to be
say i don't know that's he's pulling out
all the stops he's going across
the world because he doesn't want to
deal with it he wants the situation to
settle down for a couple weeks i think
i think the more interesting question is
will trump also be gone from dc
by that point so that they'll they'll
essentially have completely vacated in
that
there's speculation that this next
weekend trump may leave dc go to florida
for for the holiday and just never come
back
we've not seen him publicly for weeks at
this point he has nothing on his
schedule ever
if he was already gone by january 6th
and mike pence was leaving up until
close to inauguration day i mean i think
the optics of it would be kind of weird
but it's hard to imagine it's for
security well there are three uh
possibilities we've discussed when it
comes to trump
yeah uh one is that he leaves before
christmas
another is that he takes air force one
down to florida to hold an
inauguration day rally there and the
third one is he just locks himself in
the oval
office and is forced out by secret
service uh i think
that last one would be the most
entertaining of course i would like to
see that the most i think it'd be
terrible for the country
terrible for the country but great for
entertainment that yeah of course sure
i think uh the most likely scenario is
the second one where he goes down to
florida the morning of january 20th and
he has some big campaign
speech down there he takes air force one
down but they have to return without him
back up to washington
i think that's the most likely thing
that that'll happen yeah i i have a
feeling he's not just going to vacate dc
permanently this weekend i i do think
that he'll stick around
uh but honestly i also didn't think that
at this late stage he would be thinking
of appointing sydney powell
special counsel to investigate voter
fraud
or talking about forcibly seizing voting
machines and martial law
in the oval office so i don't know what
the hell to expect
well we knew that trump would try to
challenge
the election results in the courts and
he's done exactly that
over these over the past month or so and
we knew that he would keep doing that
until the electoral college voted and
until congress certified the votes
and there are some people speculating
that maybe he'll want to declare martial
law
in the last two weeks in between when
congress counts the votes and when biden
is inaugurated
yeah and it seems just way too drastic
of a move it doesn't seem like
we could have an american president who
does something like that this day and
age
but it's trump after all and yeah the
option is being considered
i don't think he'll do it i think trump
would i think trump would do it i think
trump there's no
i don't think trump has the moral
objection to it or a concern about how
bad it would be for the country
i just don't think he will do it and i
don't even know that it's clear that he
really could do what he
imagines that it would mean to declare
martial law i think it would actually be
something his advisors would be able to
explain to him it won't even achieve
what you want it to achieve
but it will make him look strong it'll
make him look like he's at least trying
and he has nothing to lose
right i mean even if it makes him look
bad amongst
progressives and people who actually
care about the country his base is still
going to love it
maybe that will ensure him getting the
republican nomination in 2024
there is probably value to him doing
something like that
although it's probably not gonna happen
uh but you know it's we can't put it
past him yeah i if if you know i'm
betting there's no martial law but the
fact
again there's a lot of people there's a
lot of republicans who were interviewed
this weekend pat about trump
thinking about it and most of them
simply said
listen trump's not actually going to do
it that was their defense
and the problem i don't i also don't
think trump's going to do it the problem
is the president is even talking about
it in the oval office after losing an
election
that's the problem hasn't there been a
problem with people underestimating
trump though
yeah and sometimes they get proven wrong
for doing that sure so like this could
be
the final thing that he has right this
is his final play this is his final act
as president
yeah put it past him i i again i i would
not put it past him
morally i think he just won't be able to
get it together
and i don't think it'll happen but i
want to hear from you guys we are here
the rest of this week
off next week we'll see you tomorrow
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
you